what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
jte movie thinks follow his YouTube
channel immediately I am JT E's newest
best friend I'm going to be the best man
at his wedding and then we will be
lovers and he will leave his wife for me
everything he said is true and at Porat
but nothing more important than going to
my channel and hitting a subscription do
it what are you waiting for
watch this video trailers revisited
we're gonna do a treasure visited what
that is we revisit trust you know how
accurately portrayed was the movie with
the trailer we've done it for a few
people really like them and we see if
it's for the rific if it gets the tone
right yada yada yada you'll see how it
works today we're doing one of the most
requested ones because of affinity wars
were coming out a lot of Marvel requests
civil war trailer number two few people
don't like this is my favorite civil a
lot of people I said oh he's my favorite
trailer I was so pumped for this movie
Burke came out so I'm excited watching
let's check this out and we'll talk
about it
this job try to save as many people as
we can the opening scene
that's L have hired an awesome sometimes
it doesn't mean everybody
you don't give up
[Music]
you know I love that movie Washington
did you see Attorney General I remember
that was exciting
yeah okay that's enough captain people
are afraid that's why I'm here
they're gonna hide you that we need be
put in check
whatever form that takes I'm game I'm
sorry Tony if I see a situation pointed
South I can't ignore it
actually could sometimes I want to punch
you in your perfect teeth
[Music]
but the safest names are still out this
is a great movie
however this was a big moment into chess
[Music]
not the one that needs to watch their
back this doesn't have to end in a fight
Tony
my seat
[Music]
oh yeah I remember a jacket about that
final warning
I can do saw me do this all day
Greg call back
[Music]
I said how it goes in the movie right
yeah no no he doesn't he doesn't flip in
Atlanta he didn't say hey everyone there
he's like gets up and starts ah hey
everyone it's a different shot it's a
different shot actually yeah he says hey
everyone it's perfect thank you yeah we
don't really need to start a
conversation okay cat captain big fan
spider-man yeah we'll talk about it
later
just everyone if you jump sometimes when
I do these shows revisited I'm often
like they've kind of beat out the whole
movie for you or they show you
everything and marble is very much like
they either do such a good job at
keeping it secret and keeping things
hidden or they do a great job at
spoiling too much and this is one of the
great examples of keeping things hidden
and not knowing exactly how things will
play it was Dimona trailer no schemas on
the trailer and almost not even industry
they were smart in their marketing cuz I
get all about Ironman and cap going
toe-to-toe with each other that was a
big marketing peal and that is the
essence of this movie of what it all
builds to they give stuff here where
it's like everyone's chasing down Bucky
but you're like oh yeah it's a Winter
Soldier makes sense whether yeah they
don't give away a lot of the actual plot
they just reveal a lot of themes and
what the conflict and like the central
conflict is about which I appreciate it
what they do in the marketing here I
think when you walked away from this
movie I think specially saw in theaters
a lot of people walked away talking
about the airport scene yeah and this
they tease it they show you very little
this stuff they do shows them running
each other you don't get a lot of actual
fighting which I really enjoyed cuz
safer for the theater I was surprised
what I forgot watching this they show
war machine going down I remember that
in the trailer remember a lot of people
were freaking out about oh I don't want
a small anything for infinity war but
that's why I was kind of feeling like
some things would be misleading and
infinity war but they actually they play
that moment up in trailers holding them
is like yeah damn they play it up a
little more here than it actually
because in the movie it's like an
ineffective moment but then quickly you
realize like all right it's gonna be
fine
but they don't give like again Zemo and
some of the things that yeah
bring it all together like I'm never
walking as we think in captain iron
aren't really gonna go at it what could
really come in between them and then
when they show the video and Winter
Soldier is killing his mom it's like
yeah the gloves are oh yeah he's gonna f
[ __ ] up and he goes even says it he's
like he killed my mom see I didn't see
that twist coming no some people claim
they saw you did good on you I had no
idea what I saw I was like oh snap I
want to comment on that because in the
trailers and there's even in another
trailer where they show like Bucky cool
shot they're like the exact enough Iron
Man Dawson the shield off his head at
first when I was watching the movie I
was kind of bummed that they showed any
of that in the trailer because if you
remember how the movie plays out
Iron Man learns that Bucky didn't really
bomb the place and then he's like yeah
we're cool mentoring candid a funny line
yeah mentoring candidate you're killing
me there's a truce here you can drop do
you think they're cool that way yeah but
because I saw the trailer I'm like no
wait there's that fight coming right but
then when you see the twist I'm like oh
I didn't know that's why they be
fighting yeah I really watched all these
movies leading up to the war and some
wars it's one of the top it's part of
the top and yeah yeah it is so good and
I remember to the excitement too of
general Ross being back yeah this
trailer revealing that because we were
like oh that Hulk movie actually can't
oh yeah this movie did happen during our
time was when Agent Coulson brought in
Avengers Iron Man like all the files
yeah and I'm showing some of the school
fight but outside of that like these
just never really acknowledged I think
this is like a perfect trailer it's like
what I have would like to have not seen
at that this whole sequence and at the
end fight would I've not liked to have
seen that sure yeah but there were still
surprises to be had because they leave
Zemo out of the trailers they play the
marketing on this is brilliant like this
is how you should market your movies and
I think infinity war they did a great
job they're doing there's like the Iron
Man 1 trailers and then there's the
homecoming trailers and then there's
like the Civil War trailers there
got a second trailer for it man the wasp
and they give you some stuff what's
going on but I still don't know what the
main villain to what their goal is like
there's a lot of things I left out there
at the point over they don't need to do
it much gonna do my god I have a Marvel
coming out there's somebody some cool
stuff we could save things like I mean
not maybe the franchise's could do that
and I'm glad that I kept this as a
serious trip sometimes I feel like
Marvel will do serious chillers for
movies that are funny I got saw a
homecoming trailer that was like a
really serious trailer oh my god that
movies pretty funny though that's like a
comedy and there's some humor in here no
but I would say that majority of the
movies actually pretty serious fellow if
any war was funnier than I thought was
gonna be I mean yeah that does true has
been all Dredd movie I was like there's
a lot of good interplay
I think they managed to capture the town
pretty well here I mean yeah and then
when the humor felt appropriate in this
movie so yeah this is one of those few
trailers or visit about money yeah they
nailed this movie they nailed the trust
month ago and watch this trailer makes
me want to go yeah great film is a great
film there is some Marvel movies you're
like that's a Marvel movie and then
there are some movies you're like and
it's a me Civil War is a film again this
is what Marvel is doing they have all
these characters that you're already
have these built relationships with and
it's like a shorthand like yeah it's
almost a cheat code they don't have to
spend half the movie introducing
characters you could just jump right in
to be like I know who they are
another backstory tell me what are the
next day alright guys well hey trailers
revisited for Captain America Civil War
leave recommendations down below for
what you recommend is good to revisit I
prefer them when they're like trailers
that totally misrepresent the movie
those are way more fun to rip apart by
the way let's get a Howard the Duck
misrepresented
because really great movie looks like it
could be entertaining and then you watch
it you're like yeah well you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Bell jte has a channel
two movie things sheets yeah Ruby thinks
join the JT movie things nation I'm
still missing a finger I need like leak
along Joanna thinks Accords there you go
leave a comment for what he could say
yeah what can they be thinkers and
become a patron ejecta day that's where
we call the patrons we patronage X
patriotic X that was right up H fron
edge X I'm not gonna I can say a pitcher
on it now create Rhino Jack's see him on
screen Duggars in Collider bike